president Donald Trump said my first
guest is filthy and there's nothing
funny about what he says that's how we
choose our guest here he's the host of
The Late Show with Stephen Colbert
please welcome Stephen Colbert
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
take
[Applause]
good to be here good to be here and I
have to say thank you yeah you are the
coolest whaler I've seen and I just
found this backstage yeah oh really yeah
there's all kinds of stuff back there
yes we're gonna hunt for the horrible
sperm all gonna be wailing songs tonight
I'm so happy to be here you know this is
Tina said I believe this is correct this
is your first time on this stage I've
never been on stage at the apollo before
with Conan O'Brien yeah the knee icon of
late night if you don't mind me saying
you are the living breathing you are the
living history of late night my friend
yeah Mandarin anybody see the incredible
article today in the New York Times
about throwing it I have not seen it but
I hear wonderful well deserved that
rumor well-deserved I wrote it myself
you